ricky klim and cbs news legal analyst so
alan weiselberg chief financial officer
of the trump organization if he pleads
guilty what could that mean for the
former president
what we've learned is that ellen
weisselberg intends to plead guilty and
surprisingly he is going to cooperate
not directly against the former
president but against the trump
organization and the people involved in
payroll because what you're dealing with
here is a plea of guilty to tax
violations where he got perks and things
like tuition cards rent and that they
were not accounted for properly the
president may still be in the clear as
to this case all right let's talk about
the white house documents investigation
the search of mar-a-lago that search
based on an affidavit if the affidavit
is uh unsealed and revealed to the
public what would be in there
potentially the concern of the justice
department and apparently they're
adamantly concerned that they do not
want this affidavit to become public is
because it not only paints the picture
of what led up to the search warrant
being issued which has to do with then
perhaps uncovering sources but it also
goes forward as to what the scope of
this investigation and perhaps other
investigations are
so they would like to keep that secret
now things happen in court that don't
often happen on the paperwork so it is
possible and i underlined possible that
there may be a compromise where some of
the affidavit is public but only i think
if the justice department wants it all
right we shall see to the georgia
election interference case rudy giuliani
is a target in that criminal probe
and he testified before a special grand
jury there this week what are you
watching in that case i think that's the
most dangerous case for donald trump one
of the things you have to consider is
that this special grand jury is going
forward with a wide-ranging
investigation
in the unlikely event but anything again
is possible a prosecutor could decide
they want rudy giuliani's cooperation
despite how high up he is in the chain
to directly go after donald trump if
that were the case they could give rudy
use immunity and demand that he testify
or else go to jail he's older he's in
his late 70s he certainly does not want
to go to prison
that case is really bubbling
and if that grand jury investigative
body comes back with a report that looks
like they have enough to go forward
against donald trump that's where i'd be
worried again donald trump we know is
concerned because he's hired one of the
finest criminal defense lawyers in the
country in georgia that's drew finley
and drew finley knows his way around the
georgia courts he's tough that's the
case we'll be watching that is a signal
if alan weisselberg to go back to the
news of today pleads guilty by my count
this morning that would be at least the
sixth close trump ally or aide to plead
guilty to a felony or be convicted of
one and gail on that note i will send it
back to you ricky kleeman thank you very
much thank you john